how's it goin everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and of course the MCU today we
are talking about Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness big news today
about Sam Raimi but real quick if you
didn't check out my video yesterday
about the venom 2 trailer not happening
please check it out after this video and
again I'd like to apologize to everybody
but today we do have some very exciting
news it has been officially confirmed
Sam Raimi himself has said that he is on
board with Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness now this was
reported by different media outlets in
the past but this is the first time that
he himself has actually confirmed it and
this confirmation and some comments that
he made in a recent interview could mean
that Spider Man Tobey Maguire spider-man
could be showing up in Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness we're
gonna break it all down but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up-to-date on all Marvel content and to
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 and picking the winner
at 550,000 subscribers almost there so
most of you know that scott derrickson
who directed the first Doctor Strange
film was supposed to direct the second
Doctor Strange film however due to some
differences we'll call it him in Marvel
Studios have parted ways but he is still
on as an executive producer Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness is
supposed to be the Marvel Cinematic
Universe his first horror story type of
film but it wasn't too long after that
word began to go around that Marvel
Studios had found another horror
director to helm the project and that
was none other than Sam Raimi the
director of the first spider-man trilogy
and yesterday that was officially
confirmed by Sam Raimi himself in an
interview with comingsoon.net and in the
interview they were talking to Sam Raimi
about the scene in spider-man 2 where
they named drop dr. strange dr. strange
that's pretty good it was taken and in
regards to this scene in the upcoming
Doctor Strange multiverse of madness
film this is what Sam Raimi had to say I
loved dr. strange as a kid but he was
always after spider-man and Batman for
me
he was probably at number five for me of
great comic book characters he was so
original but when we had that moment in
spider-man 2 I had no idea that we would
ever
be making a Doctor Strange movie so it
was really funny to me that
coincidentally that line was in the
movie I gotta say I wish we had the
foresight to know that I was going to be
involved in the project so what Sam
Raimi said in this interview confirms
two things one is that he is officially
on board with the film to direct he is
our new director for the film Andy has a
horror background as well so the film
should keep the same tone and two is
what everybody really wants is that now
there is a definite possibility that
spider-man Tobey Maguire spider-man
could be in dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness this is definitely
something that Sam Raimi and Marvel
Studios are going to consider especially
with a film that involves the multiverse
and lets reexamine that last line Sam
Raimi said I gotta say I wish we had the
foresight to know that I was going to be
involved in the project the reason that
he is saying this is he would have
undoubtedly connected the two in some
way he would have set up Doctor Strange
more in spider-man 2 or possibly
spider-man 3 but of course there was no
way to know this at the time the MCU
wasn't even in existence yet even though
Sam Raimi kind of attempted a mini MCU
in spider-man 2 by referencing Doctor
Strange so obviously he can't go back
and change spider-man 2 but what he can
do is throw something in Doctor Strange
2 since we are exploring different
realities and multiverses you can
definitely connect the two of them
together in fact an alternate version of
Doctor Strange could reference Tobey
Maguire spider-man or perhaps our
current timeline Doctor Strange as he
goes through different universes so Sam
Raimi is directing multiverse of madness
and he wishes that he would have known
this because he would have connected the
two films but it's not too late he will
still have a chance to do that in
multiverse of madness which is of course
what we all would absolutely freak out
over so let me know what you think about
this awesome news and let me know how
much you would love for Tobey Maguire
spider-man to show up in multiverse of
madness and let me know if you'd like to
see anybody else show up as well be sure
to leave a like on the video and
subscribe but notifications turned on so
you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU you can follow me on
Twitter for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof